hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals kant engages shortly after
talking about the good will
in a kind of digression that
may throw you when you're when you're
reading through it for the first or
second
or you know however many many times
and he starts talking about why we were
given reason why
that's part of our being as human beings
um you know what good does it do what is
it for
and he's adopting a kind of
fairly
uncommitted to any sort of you know
creator or anything like that but a
teleological
perspective on
the universe on human beings on being in
general by by bringing this up and he
why is he bringing this up in the first
place why is he going into a digression
well it has to do with the will
the good will
what's the point of having a good will
we saw that it's not
um you know just so it brings about good
effects or anything like that
so
why would we have something like that
does that make sense for us so he says
um
there must arise the suspicion that
perhaps it's secret basis where it's
coming from
is some high-flow fantasticality and we
have made we have misunderstood the
purpose of nature
in attaching reason to our will as its
governor so
why were we given reason so that reason
could direct the will as a matter of
fact kant will say
at a number of places is kind of a
tricky thing to make sense of that the
will is practical reason or reason
practically you know working
um
so reason
is directing the will the will is
directing our activity
our motives making us into what it is
that we we want to be
or desire to be or choose to be
why though what's the whole point behind
all of this
so
he says we're going to submit our idea
to an examination from this point of
view
in the natural constitution of an organ
an organic being one can try for the
purpose of life so there's already some
some
teleology or the study of purposes or
ends or or reasons here involved
one can try for the purpose of life let
us take it as a principle that in it no
organ is to be found for any end unless
it is the most appropriate to that end
and the best fitted for it
so that's already kind of a stretch
right if you know much about physiology
you know we have appendices i'm not even
sure where it's located but you know it
used to serve a purpose but doesn't
serve a purpose anymore
certainly not the best adapted to what
it does but let's just go with on that
okay
so
suppose now that for a being possessed
of reason and a will the real purpose of
nature or his preservation his welfare
or in a word his happiness so that's one
of the possible answers or actually two
sets of answers to this question right
why were we given reason
well maybe it's so that we could better
pursue happiness and we have to explore
this question well what does that mean
what is happiness we'll do that you know
some some other place
or maybe it's self-preservation um you
know and kant's not neatly
distinguishing these but if we're
thinking about this in in our own times
there's plenty of people out there who
think that
the reason why we have the kinds of
brains and therefore the kind of
intellectual processes that we do
and the capacity for choice that we do
is it it leads us to having better
outcomes in terms of you know survival
or
you know passing on our genetic material
that's what you know evolution is
supposed to to attain right um
so count is is considering these these
possibilities
let's say
just assuming that that's actually the
case
so
did whatever gave us reason did that do
a good job in doing that if that's the
goal being happy
or
just self-preservation did it do a
really good job
well kant's the answer is no
let's look at why
he says
for all the actions he has to perform
with this end in view and the whole rule
of its behavior
if you wanted to be happy
and we have to actually pause here for a
second what does it mean to be happy kat
says that happiness is kind of a vague
indistinct idea
and i'm going to do another core concept
on that where we explore that in a bit
more detail
suffice it to say for here what does
happiness mean kant says it means the
satisfaction of our desires and
inclinations so whatever it is that you
desire pick the whole batch of it right
whatever it is that you desire not just
now but also later on so if you're you
know a kid you desire some things later
on you become an adult you start to
realize that you desire other things get
a bit older you desire other things
the satisfaction of all of those and
your inclinations
that's happiness
so let's say we can't actually wrap our
heads around that
does reason help us with that well you
know some philosophers think so you know
we can sort of like balance we you know
we
figure out what the end is we want to be
happy now we figure out all the means
and we balance the means to fit the end
kant says you know actually if you
wanted to do that sort of thing you'd
have been better off just implanting
instincts in us that would make us do
that fairly automatically like dogs or
cats
or earthworms do i mean earthworms the
satisfaction of their desires and
inclinations is to dig around in the mud
and bump up against each other and mate
and uh eat stuff and excrete stuff and
not get pulled apart i guess that's
that's pretty much it for them and they
do a pretty good job in attaining that
for the most part um
actually they like to come up to the
surface when it rains not because they
have to but because they they
people think
there's there's some sort of
you know desire on their part to do that
but it's an instinct right
if
we were intended by nature only to aim
at happiness if that was the highest
limit
then it would made sense to give us
instincts that would have made that
happen for us
and you could say well you know we do
have instincts um we want to eat we want
to you know drink we want to
engage in sex we want to sleep you know
we have
we want to be warm we want to be dry
when we're wet
um
maybe reason could take these in and
kind of process them and and
tell us what to do but you know that's
kind of a low level isn't it we don't
have instincts that
tell us
think about the universe
or if we do it it doesn't work
infallibly the way that animal instincts
seem to in many cases
and it doesn't even seem to have like
this sort of workings that
other
drives do
so that doesn't work
so we we haven't been given these he
says
in actual fact we also find that the
more cultivated reason concerns itself
with the aim of enjoying life and
happiness the further does man get away
from true contentment
so
this is funny because kant is saying
when we do actually practically reason
those of us who spend time
trying to figure out hey i i understand
now what's going to make me happy
what do i have to do to get over there
to get that that stuff that makes me
happy
he says
um
this leads to this kind of hatred of
reason for when they balance all the
advantage they draw i will not say from
thinking out the arts of ordinary
indulgence but even of science they
discover they have in fact only brought
more trouble on their heads than they
have gained in the way of happiness
this is very interesting on this account
they come to envy rather than to despise
the more common run of men so those who
like map out their life
and think it out you know thoroughly and
use reason here's the end you know what
are the means what are the means to
those means what are the means
kant thinks that if you look at them
and here is kind of making an empirical
argument isn't he you know a guy who
says he's you know against making
empirical arguments he says if you look
at them
they tend to be less happy than the
people who just kind of willy-nilly go
through things and bump into happiness
over here and
and uh over here and just kind of you
know
uh
things fall into place for them
neither one end up being particularly
happy
neither one of them get all of their
desires and satisfactions
desires and inclination satisfied
but the one who uses reason actually
ends up getting less of what he says now
i i don't know if that's really the case
um but let's go with kant for for a
moment let's assume that that actually
is the case
so he says um
reason is not
sufficiently serviceable
for guiding the will safely as regards
its objects and the satisfaction of all
our needs
which in fact it even multiplies because
you know he's right there if you think
about it as soon as you start using
reason which isn't just a matter of like
having you know premises and then
reasoning to conclusions
it's a matter of looking at the world
and saying there's a lot of
possibilities there i could i could do
some things i could apply the technology
that i have here to change this make it
better
i could even this process out once you
start doing that just i mean start
applying that to your own life just just
focus just on your own life or just one
pick one area of it
you start doing that you find more
projects and more plans than you would
ever have time to carry out
and how does that feel that doesn't
actually make you feel happy
that now gives you more desires which
are not going to be satisfied
so
kant says
an implanted natural instinct would have
led us much more
surely
uh but nonetheless reason has been
imparted to us as a practical power
that is one which is to have influence
on the will so what is
the purpose
if it's not to make us happy because it
doesn't do that very well
and it's not just to attain
you know survival as a matter of fact if
you want to survive certain situations
you probably shouldn't think too much
right you should probably ignore a lot
of the the factors that reason would say
hey look over there and check that out
and you wouldn't want to spend a lot of
time you know processing things if it's
you know do or die
fight or flee those sorts of situations
well if reason isn't for that
then
what is it for
what other purpose
would there be in giving us reason which
could then tell the will
what to do you know rather than say
instincts directing the will as they do
in animals
or you know
something like
problem solving but at a much lower
level perhaps
why do we have this this faculty that's
unparalleled in all the other species
that we come across
well another possibility is
we're supposed to be aiming at something
higher than happiness
that's not to say that happiness is a
bad thing
for kante actually thinks we have a duty
to try to work for other people's
happiness
and that it's not bad if we work for our
own happiness provided it doesn't keep
us from doing our duty
but we do have a higher calling you
might say
something woven into the very fabric of
the beings that we are can't thinks
and that is to
do duty
for the sake of duty for the right
reason for the right motive
that's a matter of a kind of willing
that's the good will
and so he says
reason has been imparted to us as a
practical power
that is as one which is to have
influence on the will its true function
must be
to produce a will which is good
not as a means to some other end so not
because it gets us praise or because it
will lead us to you know being happy
because you know we'll get everything
that we want
but because there's a goodness intrinsic
to the will itself when it is a good
will it's not good for something else
it's not good on account of something
else it is good in itself
and the purpose of reason
context
is to
be our tool
by which we actually bring that about in
ourselves we make ourselves into
the good will the conscient good will
so he says a will which is good not as a
means to some other end but in itself
for this function reason was absolutely
necessary in a world where nature
has ever gone to work with the purpose
of manner
he says this doesn't have to be the only
good
such a will need not on this account be
the soul and complete good but it must
be the highest good
and the condition of all the rest even
of our demands for happiness so
kant is thinking that the reason why
we're given reason the reason for reason
is that we can actually produce
something that goes beyond the realm of
mere nature as we experience it here
goes beyond what we start with and
refines that best part of ourselves
to make it into what it could be what
its potential is
and his way of thinking about this
there's other people who have thought
you know similar thoughts his way of
thinking about this centers around
the conception of of duty as being that
which we ought to will
there's a certain purity here on kant's
view
one that you know whether you agree with
it or to disagree with it it has to be
acknowledged
he's sort of eclipsing the
question of happiness and saying that's
that's down here
but humanity is all the way
from the top to the bottom
and this stuff up here is
way more important than the stuff that's
just down here
and we have to attend to it and and no
amount of like piling things up
in terms of happiness survival is going
to get you to morality so kant is
setting a clear
incision a
a
dividing line
i
in a way i've got an articulator on
because here's the lower and here's the
higher on the board but this is what's
higher
this is what's lower
so
that's the purpose of rationality
that's what we're supposed to be
directed towards according to kant